the Gillman bread my name is we're back
welcome back to some more Mike pixel I'm
glad you brought love this game as much
as I did because it's freakin hilarious
to play it we're gonna go to chef de
tres I think right now up nice back kick
bro
hey we got bad man Super Mario Darth
Vader alien okay I guess you take the
ticket and give it to little Timmy ma
now you little [ __ ] Timmy I'll give it a
dog waiting
don't be very more like it look like it
fine I give it a year fine you know what
to Narnia this is my stuff right day
chapter three run one holiday blast ah
we're going to the moon always wanted to
go as this is our only [ __ ] uh hey there
I don't know how I'm breathing without a
mask but it's pretty cool here let me
kick you you're welcome
Ben the moon expla [ __ ] okay we're in
the jungle Amanda lysis jungle back then
I don't know what they're called vacuum
cleaner probably not it and we got a
blonde Tasha I think I'm gonna go for
the blonde Tasha no no I don't have big
Tasha yeah why did you do that talk on
that's what you get for kicking a man in
the nuts they start humping you alright
nice scarf let me get that no well let
me get this custard and let me give it
to you yes drink all of that up what's
going on here why did he jump up up what
I love his face
but it's going on and of course we jump
as well that was the best solution I
have ever seen
holy [ __ ] that was actually a solution
okay oh it's Bigfoot
hey Beck bud you know what I should
probably clean your hair but I'm gonna
use this here instead bad idea bad idea
why the [ __ ] did I do that I don't have
answers for everything back here oh yeah
we're in the bank and you're a thief
you're police you should not be doing
this let me click the code don't worry I
know what I'm doing
yeah Mac me oh dear
that was the solution apparently all
right let's jump through oh no no no
okay
let's go to the side hey he's not happy
about that sorry about your flag bro
okay and stretch trip vacuum cleaner oh
he has the bomb okay yep let's clean his
hair this time here you go man
don't even worry about it I'm a
professional no mountains still explodes
okay this time we will take the bomb it
will take his nose we will take his
shoes we will take this why the hell did
I do it again okay take the bomb and
give it to the flag Pro crow
goddamnit okay Leon Leon let's kick this
yeah yeah cuz everyone knows if you drop
one tonne of all right um Wow
why do you kick it it's okay I got this
one we just click here ha yeah there you
let may all that okay this time we will
take the bomb and give it to the
customer now you go start later huh
no why is that it's a solution to blow
up the earth instead really if you make
this one we will get a bonus okay
think really hard PIDs think really our
look around what do we see hi I can't
see [ __ ] I think we're screwed actually
what if we grab this and eat it
1.7% I have no idea what the [ __ ] just
happened that was probably a reference
to something but I have no idea
yes max hair Ania bonus round
you okay uh we took that one last time
so let's go for this one
oh nothing what about you what about you
what about this one ah okay and give it
to him give it to him we don't have a
lot of time go you take him
I don't [ __ ] know what ah what am i
doing I don't think I saw that one I
don't think up which solved this one at
least the detected addicted to to to to
to to to to to to genius Paris facts
again to get a detector to do to do to
do to do to do to do let's go jump right
into chapter 2 hey go sir hey you guys
I'm take me two hot words please thank
you very much
Chapter three round two wanna be one of
them wannabe Manabu mad about meta boom
farm it should be good
oh it's Cali I miss you man ever since I
put that bone inside your [ __ ] okay
let me ah
now why would I do that J can't you
can't do that what is that what am i gay
why am i why did I yeah
alright it might be solid why don't you
what is what is this oh come on Mike
stars star just not done okay
everybody man other than Batman you want
this Batman of course
everyone knows if you do that a bad man
and he lids up let's click the whole sky
later yep I should solve the critical
mass failure we're at that okay there's
a chicken in an old man let's actually
go for his King Marchan you're doing wah
wah ba-bah shut up shut up
take it up your [ __ ] and spin and fly
of course how do you like that chicken
beautiful yes yes it all makes sense I
was planning for that to happen you
don't even worry about it
totally and my let's take the gas and
kill him check with still exploit okay
well he has dynamite hi stop having
dynamite what about here I love it space
we try to do something like okay Mike
here we did one at least we need a ship
up that was pretty terrible no oh I got
a hurt
damn that was a solution
shooting the okay I'll take it don't
even worry about it
okay this time we will take this and put
it to this clicked okay thank you for
that
can we take this critical ass of course
thank you for that backpack shell let's
take the cow oh holy [ __ ] we can take
account okay what do we do we yeah
whatever do we yeah we're given to him
again yes gorgeous hat very nice hat
okay now we take this just put it on the
bomb yes
I've no idea what that does yeah it
kills us
okay um what about here like that that
was not a solution
all right we take the cow and we put the
cow here ah poor cow
that was a solution [ __ ] okay we take
this really dude that one didn't man
we're [ __ ] okay um thank you pity
think what is this did we do it did we
save dick yeah Mac beard yeah dig in eh
baby all right let's take the cow and
give it to the elephant oh why didn't I
think of that sooner
seriously okay we have to now come on
one more baby one more baby oh no more
I'm Baba let's just go straight a bad
man
and man do something cool bull [ __ ] okay
let's just go straight to the bomb man
are you kidding me okay
yeah and in it I get it
look at [ __ ] like the leg I get it
nananananana nananananana nananananana
nananananana
nananananana ha happened here debit
debit sorry sorry sigh all right cool
I think that will be it for today hope
you bros enjoyed always a pleasure to
play this game like a Finnish you want
to become subscribe and stuff then ha ha
ha you're scared keep watching
otherwise I'll get you dynamite is back
there's nothing behind me don't be
ridiculous okay no what are you doing oh
[ __ ] my [ __ ]